le sujet de l'immigration alors là aussi
il y avait débat il y avait débat hier
soir sur le plateau de ces news entre
les chefs de parti du chef de file des
partis sur l'immigration la question n'a
peut-être elle pas été au coeur du grand
débat mais elle reste certainement une
préoccupation des français
ce qui n'a pas échappé au président de
la république qui va sans doute en faire
un de ses axes dans les son intervention
post grand débat attendu la semaine
prochaine
une façon aussi pour lui de mordre sur
un électorat de droite et de ne pas
laisser le sujet à laurent wauquiez ou à
marine le pen
le figaro consacre deux pages à ce sujet
politique demain et nous on en parle
tout de suite mais avant je vous propose
de regarder un extrait de ce débat hier
soir c'était sur ses news
il opposait vous allez voir une passe
d'armes entre stanislas guerrini délégué
général de la république en marche et
ensuite la réponse que lui fait olivier
faur patron des socialistes
la vérité aussi c'est que notre
organisation de l'asile en europe ne
fonctionne pas à ce que l'oratrice
défendre les frontières de l'europe que
l'on puisse défendre les frontières de
l'europe
c'est exactement ce que le président de
la république a proposé j'aimerais que
vous reveniez à se caler votre identité
première que vous sachiez pour retrouver
ont été retrouvées au sol parce que
aujourd'hui on ne sait plus très bien où
vous êtes
à force de dérivés sont fines et c'est
sur le plan économique sur le plan
social et y compris sur le plan fort des
questions migratoires à occuper un
espace qui n'aurait jamais dû être celui
de quelqu'un qui se prétend de
progressis sherbrooke vous être aussi
sévère qu olivier faur veille de
stanislas guérini l'a perdu la boussole
la boule parce que ce que met en exergue
olivier faure pour faire non pas son
avocat mais pour aller dans son sens
entre ce que dit emmanuel macron
candidat à la présidentielle sur
notamment l'accueil des réfugiés en
allemagne où il cite en exemple plus ou
moins angela merkel et les huit cent
mille réfugiés qui sont accueillis en
allemagne et la politique que met en
place
emmanuel macron et les signaux qu'il
envoie depuis quelques temps un
électorat plutôt de droite ça va avec la
loi asile immigration qui a mis quand
même en émoi pas mal d'associations et
d'acteurs qui n'attendaient pas à ça ça
va sur différents petits points c'est la
dernière sortie de castaner par rapport
à dans un instant sera fait qu'à un
moment donné il n'est pas faux de dire
que il
à une espèce de dérive entre le discours
du candidat macro et la réalité d'une
politique qui le met en place et on le
sait la politique stratégique mende
emmanuel macron est plutôt d'aller
mordre sur un électorat qui est un petit
peu plus captifs et consistant
aujourd'hui et le fait est que la
bascule politique elle n'est pas du côté
de la gauche elle est plutôt que du côté
de la droite et c'est par là où il donne
aujourd'hui plutôt des signes et des
indications plutôt que sur sa gauche et
donc toute la politique qu'il met en
oeuvre récemment pendant le grand débat
il a évoqué de remettre en place les
quotas qui était une idée qu'avait lancé
notamment à une époque françois fillon
s'était pas par hasard c'est un signal
qui parlent bien un électorat et pas
celui de gauche donc dire que le
discours de la présidentielle ne s'est
pas traduit dans les faits que c'est une
autre politique qui est menée
aujourd'hui par le gouvernement et par
emmanuel macron n'est pas faux et ce que
dit olivier faure c'est qu'on n'y
comprend pas grand chose aujourd'hui
entre ce qu'on nous avait promis et ce
qui est en place et je pense que c'est
pas faux sur un plan factuel
après est-ce que olivier faure a raison
on rentre dans le débat politique sur
les mesures mais sur la tendance d'une
dérive
oui il fait de la triangulation pour
réciter ce que dodi richard week c'est à
dire qu'il va chasser sur les terres de
droite et reprendre un thème cher à la
droite qui n'a pas de colonne vertébrale
idéologique en matière régaliennes
emmanuel macron il n'est pas structuré
il pense pas on vous a fait croire je me
rappelle d'un éditorialiste qui nous
disaient qu'ils avaient même écrit un
essai sur mac qui avait complètement
délirant vous assurer qu'il avait écrit
sur moi qui avais je leur ai lu donc ça
a jamais existé ça c'était manuel
makonda n'existe pas emmanuel macron
c'est l'udf
ok donc à droite on aère père udf qui
forme l'ump on a oublié qu'en réalité
ces deux droites là sont pas vraiment
considérable mais elles ont marché
ensemble pendant très longtemps
elles ont fait des alliances emmanuel
macron n'a pas fait apparaître un
nouveau monde
il a simplement changé le système des
alliances il a pris l'udf et l'a liée
aux gardiens
c'est ça qu'il a fait et aujourd'hui on
est en train de se rendre compte que les
rocardiens gueule elise mais attendez
c'est que c'est que c'est quoi ces
promesses qui avaient de faire quelque
chose de gauche parce qu'il venait de la
gauche parce qu'on pensait que c'est un
gars qui venait chez roccat mais en
réalité c'est un libéral tous les
libéraux tous les modérés de l'udf l'ont
rejoint et ça continue aujourd'hui donc
fondamentalement aujourd'hui le vrai
visage des manuels macron simplement
depuis deux ans en train d'apparaître
mais c'est un pur libéral à l'udf on se
fiche pas mal de la question de
l'immigration parce qu'il ya que
l'immigration dans sa version éco no
milk qui nous intéresse alors on a
l'impression que ces histoires de quotas
de protection de machin c'est une
histoire culturelle la tradition
française mais ça c'est de la com
politique
en réalité la seule chose qu'ils
intègrent emmanuel macron c'est qu'il ya
des flux migratoires qu'on arrêtera pas
et donc il faut absolument qu'on partage
les choses pour pouvoir récupérer chez
nous les immigrés qui nous intéresse
basta un pur calcul politicien et
comptable c'est fini je vous donne la
parole à tous les deux juste en écoute
vous y faisiez allusion les propos de
christophe castaner qui effectivement a
réamorcé ce débat c'était la semaine
dernière lorsqu'il recevait ses
homologues ministre de l'intérieur pour
un g7 à paris on écoute on méditerranée
centrale on a observé de façon tout à
fait documenté je vous le dis une réelle
collusion à certains moments entre les
trafiquants de migrants et certaines ong
on a observé que certains navires de ng
était ainsi en contact téléphonique
direct avec des passeurs qui faciliter
le départ des migrants depuis les côtes
libyennes dans des conditions
effroyables les ong dans ce cas là ont
pu se faire complice des passeurs on le
sait nathalie l'oiseau tête de liste la
république en marche lui a répondu d'une
certaine façon en disant que
on pouvait pas forcément à simuler les
eaux nv à des passeurs et que les
exemples humain était aussi important à
considérer
il ya une fracture là dessus au sein de
la république en marche vers sherbrooke
est clairement visé les interviews
aujourd'hui d'aurélien tâcher de jean
pierre mignard ses laboratoires de voilà
ce qu'il fait à riom je pense que c'est
je pense que c'est très clair mais on
l'avait déjà vu cette fracture à
l'occasion du vote de la loi
asile immigration sur lesquelles
certains avaient déjà émis sur des
mesures proposées des réticences voire
même plus que des réticences des
résistances et on sait que les propos de
christophe castaner n'ont pas été
véritablement très apprécié au sein à la
fois du gouvernement et de la république
en marche donc en gros oui il ya une
fracture sur ces sujets depuis un petit
moment et elle se révèle encore
aujourd'hui et ça donne aussi cette
impression
on ne sait pas trop à chaque fois vers
où ça va ça donne cette impression qu'il
ya pas la boussole dont parlait tout à
l'heure olivier fort que ça tangue marc
lolivier ya la question de l'immigration
économique
il ya aussi tout ce qui est quasi le
regroupement familial
on veut pas
jouer sur tous les tableaux et comment
comment s'en sortir sur non mais sur le
côté sur le côté la question la question
effectivement a sauvé par eric sinclair
s'était dire finalement on ne se
préoccupe de l'immigration que sous un
angle économique et le reste peu importe
on sait aussi qu'il ya des contraintes
parce que l'asile il ya des règles
européennes
le regroupement familial aussi donc on
peut pas jouer absolument sur tous les
leviers bon c'est ce qu'on essaye de
faire alors je dis casse ta mère est pas
une nouveauté je me semble que le moment
de l'accord ue si emmanuel macron avait
dit à peu près la même chose il a dit
exactement la même chose cet été où il
avait dit que les passeurs qui permet
aux abonnés donc il ya une forme de
s'épanouir la boussole comprend une
forme de constance et on peut dire que
castanet pour le coup et te développe
parfaitement bien la pensée du président
de la république puisqu'il ne fait il
n'est que son interprète x mois après
tant que tel et l'oiseau n'est pas
l'interprète du preston
non je n'en ai d'ailleurs comment vous
interpréter cette sortie de nathalie
l'oiseau parce que c'est ce que franck
est un dérapage il sent qu'elle a été
beaucoup trop loin le fait de dire qu'à
un moment donné est une ong pour lequel
on puisse le dire une autre mais il en
fait quasiment un le fait de dire
certaines ong tout d'un coup on a
l'impression positive sur des rapports
de frontex qui montre une véritable
conclusion le terme est un peu fort je
démontre qu'il est dit kylie kylie kylie
présent que ces rapports une position
claire déterminée de emmanuel macron
depuis 2010 est on en discuterait même
pas sauf qu'il ya un flou et c'est pour
ça qu'il va générer des gels et compris
les ong mais j'ai bien compris encore
une fois c'est parce que vous rappelez
des kwassa kwassa un donc
fondamentalement il manuel macron n'a
pas de pensée politique sur cette
question là ce qui veut dire que is to
hell rom1 chef qui n'est pas capable de
donner une ligne claire sur laquelle on
peut s'aligner et ça ça pose problème
dans les partis politiques parce que
simone veil nous rappelle que dans les
oripeaux titre on pense pas ça veut dire
que la pensée on vous la donne donc à un
moment il faut pouvoir s'aligner sur
quelque chose et sans critique un cercle
on a vraiment besoin de quelqu'un qui
dise ok maintenant ici la ligne c'est
celle là
et sur ces questions là il y en a
deux complices c'est un mot qui évoque
une valeur juridique je crois non
guillaume bigot et je suis complètement
d'accord avec mon voisin absolument son
analyse est très très convaincante mais
il faut peut-être ajouter juste un point
c'est que ça fait 40 ans qu'on est sur
la même ligne
alors je dis pas que ça fait 40 ans que
les gens n'ont pas les idées claires on
pas annonce pas une stratégie ou une
couleur que claire sur la question
migratoire
je dis que ça fait 40 ans que en fait il
y a
si vous voulez un discours qui était
assez martial face à l'opinion publique
ou assez brutale parce qu'on sait bien
que les français veulent arrêter et
coupé le robinet de l'immigration et
qu'en même temps il ya eu une approche
qui est celle du marché celle de
l'europe et même celle de la morale
parce que la morale des classes
dirigeantes n'est pas la morale la
population la population elle elle ne
traite pas la question migratoire comme
une question morale de manière assez
saine elle la traite pour ce qu'elle est
c'est-à-dire une question économique est
en fait la proche de l'immigration
marche sur la tête depuis 40 ans c'est
assez facile à comprendre
l'immigration fait le contraire de ce
qu'il faut faire l'immigration c'est
assez simple finalement
il ya des gens qui sont là depuis
longtemps il faut leur donner des
papiers pourquoi il faut leur donner des
papiers simplement parce qu'il faut pas
tolérer le travail au noir est pourquoi
il faut leur de les papiers parce qu'il
faut être humain simplement les gens
sont installés depuis des années et
ensuite ça veut dire qu'il faut faire
quoi
il faut dissuader la mise d'entrée parce
que les gens payent très cher et dont
seulement ils risquent leur vie
mais il paye de l'argent à ces passeurs
or si vous rembarquer les gens chez eux
ou s'ils voulaient remarqué au point de
départ à raison de dizaines de milliers
ou de sainte-anne aiguillé par ont
évidemment vous allez tahrir les flux
bien sûr que oui mais ça personne n'a le
courage de le faire
donc nous on donne des papiers ni ont
reconduit les gens à la frontière ont
fait le contraire de ce qu'il faut faire
nos internautes sur le sujet on vous
demander si vous trouviez le
gouvernement cohérent sur la question
migratoire 87% d'entre vous estiment que
non avec arguties qui nous dit je n'ai
aucune confiance en macron pour
l'instant il ratisse large pour les
européens nicole la notion d'asile a été
complètement dévoyée au gîte mais
aujourd'hui on considère les migrants
comme des demandeurs d'asile ce qui est
on considère tous les migrants comme des
demandeurs d'asile ce qui est
complètement faux
et quand même quelques demandeurs
d'asile qui sont déboutés l'eau dès
qu'on parle de privatisation ils sont
parés d'un leur grande majorité
effectivement je chiffres en tête mais
je crois que c'est 20 % ou autour d'eux
pourcentage dès qu'on parle de
privatisation en france et ses listes et
rim avec une migration on dépasse
l'entendement babineau olivier faure n'a
pas tort la politique migratoire et
identitaires du gouvernement n'a rien de
progressiste
j'ai perdu babineau leur voix si ça
n'est que de la communication et antoine
ce qui est bizarre c'est que quand on
critique la politique migratoire depuis
quelques années on est immédiatement
traité de xénophobe
juste une dernière petite question dans
le grand débat ça a été abordée pas
parce qu'on a des informations
contradictoires dans les restitutions
nous dînons l'immigration c'est pas
vraiment une préoccupation et en même
temps d'autres sources disent si si
c'est une préoccupation qui ressort
alors ils compris de façon assez abrupte
en disant stop au regroupement familial
et sherbrooke une idée sur le sujet dans
la mairie du 12e va organiser
oui nous avons organisé et des débats et
enfin plus exactement nous avions des
cahiers de doléances et on a organisé
des séquences de vidéos de kaledo les
entend qu'on a proposé à des gens de
venir et d'être enregistré que les
témoignages soient portées dans la
contribution auprès de la préfecture etc
on n'a pas organisé de grands débats en
tant que telle la mairie mais d'autres
acteurs ont fait dans l'arrondissement
des débats qui participaient aux grands
débats mois la plupart sur
l'arrondissement nous n'ont pas posé les
questions d'immigration
la plupart de ce que j'ai entendu
c'était d'ailleurs très majoritairement
des retraités qui posait des problèmes
concernant leur retraite qui posait des
problèmes concernant la dépendance c'est
quasiment en écho avec la manifestation
qui a aujourd'hui
mais ces sujets là et d'engagement
revenus moi j'ai pas eu le sujet non je
suis dans le 12e mais basculer moi c'est
d'accord mais je suis là où je suis élu
et je ne suis pas élu tous énormément
d'immigrés non mais c'est ce que j'ai
c'est exactement ce que j'ai un de dire
à vos amis ne m'avez pas écouté mais
c'est pas très grave
ce que vous avez une approche je l'avais
information simplement ben voilà alors
je les remercie peut-être c'est mieux de
l'avoir avant de donner à une a1 a
priori au départ c'est mieux j'ai
réalisé une question en tout cas je
pense que cette question n'a pas été au
coeur mais on a un vrai sujet sur qui a
écrit qui n'a pas écrit et de quoi on
fait la restitution
effectivement elle après que ça reste un
sujet de préoccupation en certains
territoire dans certains quartiers on le
sait et dans d'autres salles les
beaucoup moins je suis élue à paris mais
je suis originaire de l'aveyron je peux
vous dire que dans l'aveyron le sujet de
l'immigration n'a pas été porté comme
une préoccupation majeure
allez on passe à notre dernier sujet
très vite il s'agit de julian assange
alors on le sait la police britannique
l'a arrêté ce matin ils étaient reclus
depuis sept ans dans l'ambassade
d'équateur à londres
le lanceur d'alerté risque donc
maintenant d'avoir à affronter des
procédures à la fois pour les fuites
qu'il a organisée dans la sphère
wikileaks mais aussi pour des anciennes
accusations de viol qui pourraient être
relancés en suède
la première ministre britannique s'est
félicité entre deux négociations sur le
brésil sur le sujet on écoute rapidement
et puis on en parle tout de suite
frédéric saint clair rapidement est ce
que vous regrettez cette arrestation
vous êtes un défense